you also talk in the book about losing
your virginity that's a very private
moment for many of us love me more
apparently for me it was a very
important date during Obama's first term
but you talked about how about losing
your virginity tell that story
[Applause]
okay I'll do it I'll do it but then you
have to tell me yours sure yeah so I
they were these there were these two jab
not to Japanese girls I mean they would
they were friends but not together I
gotta read this again
get this part one of my friends was
dating a Japanese girl and she had a
friend who fancied me and so he said
that you know my girlfriend's friend
fancies you and you should just do it
like get it over with you know in a
sense and they were vulgar you at the
time I was 19 there was a lot of pretty
there was some pressure before that too
to have done it and I don't know it just
didn't pan out the way was I do anyway
cut to yes I say okay you know I'm gonna
hook up with this girl and then it
happens it's very anticlimactic and you
didn't have to
no there was no you didn't have to say
that part me it was that like the moment
did not live up in my mind what it was
supposed to be regardless I woke up the
next morning this girl's name this
girl's name is Yasu japanese girl her
best friend's name was Aris su so I woke
up the next morning and instead of
saying Yasu I said good morning Horace
Oh God she got really mad at me and I
was like women God expect you to know
their name after you lose your virginity
to them sorry wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]